first there's a new operation underway
at this hour to keep several caravans of
migrants from entering the u.s. after an
order from the president Pentagon
officials say more than 5,000 troops are
being sent to the u.s. southern border
with hundreds arriving today as the
Trump administration weighs its options
for stopping the flow of illegal
immigrants with an executive order
President Trump will discuss the
immigration fight in an interview on Fox
News at 10:00 p.m. tonight with Aurra
Ingram they'll also be discussing the
horrific killing of 11 people at a
Pittsburgh synagogue over the weekend
gathered together to celebrate new life
only to become the victims of a horrific
hate crime chief White House
correspondent John Roberts is on the
North Lawn with a look at how the
administration is handing all of that
tonight
handling it good evening John break it
evening to you the National Guard has
been sent to the border many times to
assist the Border Patrol but President
Trump is making an even greater show of
force dispatching 5200 active duty
military to the border in an
extraordinary move the Pentagon will be
sending forces many of them active duty
to the border with Mexico in an
exclusive interview with Laura Ingraham
to air at 10:00 p.m. tonight President
Trump said the military deployment is to
keep the caravans now numbering three
from crossing the border and end the
practice of catch and release we're
gonna have tents they're gonna be very
nice and they're gonna wait and if they
don't get asylum they get out and very
few people they don't actually if you
want to wait they don't usually get
Asylum you know that the deployment
dubbed Operation Faithful Patriot will
put 5200 troops on the border military
police engineers doctors and aviation
assets to support Customs and Border
Protection personnel our message to the
organizers and participants of this
caravan is simple we will not allow a
large group to enter the United States
in an unsafe and unlawful manner the
White House is also considering
executive or regulatory action one idea
being kicked around only allow migrants
to make asylum claims at ports of entry
meaning migrants who cross the border
illegally would not be allowed to claim
asylum in the United States there are a
lot of
options that are being discussed right
now the number one priority is looking
for ways to secure our borders the
horrific shooting at the Tree of Life
synagogue was also on the White House
agenda today press secretary Sarah
Sanders becoming visibly emotional at
times this atrocity was a chilling act
of mass murder it was an act of hatred
and above all it was an act of evil but
the president also took on his favorite
foil the news media tweeting there is
great anger in our country caused in
part by inaccurate and even fraudulent
reporting of the news the fake news
media the true enemy of the people must
stop the open and obvious hostility and
report the news accurately and fairly
while there is nothing to suggest that
synagogue killers hatred was motivated
by the media President Trump says his
tweets were justified I was in the
headline when they got him they didn't
say bomber found they talked about Trump
in the headland President Trump will
travel to Pittsburgh tomorrow and what
he hopes will be a moment of national
unity but 11 Jewish leaders from the
area have said the president is not
welcome and lasted until he fully
denounces white nationalism does the
White House believe this president has
done enough to denounced White National
the president has denounced racism
hatred and bigotry in all forms on a
number of occasions President Trump says
that he will visit Pittsburgh tomorrow
to pay his respects to the 11 people who
were killed in the synagogue he said
that he'll also visit a hospital where
he'll meet with the law enforcement
officers who was shot during the
standoff with the suspect as well as
meet with some of the victims in the
congregation who survived that horrific
shooting right mourn all this with the
panel a bit later John Roberts live in
the North Lawn John thanks